i think i want to be a dad now
well the time has come for chris mcnally
i'm excited for people to see it it's
something new it's a bit of a breath of
fresh air the wen calls the heart star
and his longtime partner julie gonzalo
are officially parents
the actress announced the surprise on
social media sharing this adorable image
of tiny fingers holding on to chris and
julie's hands
she writes in the caption quote our
hearts are full welcome baby m
it's pretty special the famously private
couple kept their baby news under wraps
until the big reveal
and while they have yet to share the
baby's name or gender
some fans are paying close attention to
the comments
as chris's co-stars pascal hutton and
andrea brooks both left a string of pink
hearts
i don't know
chris first sparked baby speculation in
late may when he attended an event
alongside fellow hallmark stars andrew
walker and wes brown
andrew posted this selfie with his buds
the caption just a few dads out on the
town along with a bunch of hashtags
including dads of instagram fatherhood
rocks and dad moments
andrew and wes became dads some time ago
but chris he had yet to be welcomed to
the club or so we thought i
do not pay very much attention to what's
going on for me personally i have a huge
barrier between myself and anything
social media i hardly ever even post
photos and while chris is a new dad he's
certainly been getting in practice on tv
allow me to be a father to your son
yeah his role as lucas bouchard on the
hit hallmark series has him spending a
lot of time with his on-screen son
we sure did
[Music]
and chris he says he's down to expand
lucas and elizabeth's family under one
condition chris you want more kids on
set you want to see uh your character
your character expand the family a bit
i'll take more highlands on set highland
supply i'm looking forward to exploring
the relationship the family dynamic and
what does lucas look like as a father
and i'm not sure what the writers have
in mind
but i'm excited to see
[Music]